is it a bird is it a plate oh
too soon now welcome to the heavy
spoiler show
i'm your host definition and now that
the boys are back in town
it's time to break down everything that
you need to know about the upcoming
season
there may be some spoilers here as we
will be talking about the upcoming plot
but i'll save that until the end of the
video in case you want to duck out
if you enjoy the breakdown then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into everything you
need to know about the boys season 2.
okay so the boys started filming in the
middle of 2019
which right now feels like a lifetime
ago
the second season was put into
production faster than a train
and amazon actually renewed it before
the first season had even aired
because well who doesn't love seeing a
superhero butcher people
is that a pun i don't even know anymore
now the second season wrapped quite
quickly
and we actually got our first trailer
back in december confirming what would
be happening in the upcoming show
with this initial look came the
announcement that the show would be
dropping on amazon prime
on september the 4th on this date we
will get the first three episodes
and then from that point onwards it will
be released weekly over the next five
fridays
i've always wondered why streaming
services put out all their episodes on
the same day
as it just gets people to start a free
trial and
then when they watch the show they can
just cancel it it seems that they've
gotten wise to this though
as we've seen this model become more and
more prevalent over the last couple of
months
with the mandalorian being the first big
thing that fit this format
since then amazon have released
follow-up teaser trailers
that not only introduce new characters
but also
discuss what they're up to the first big
one of these came in the form of
stormfront
and neo nasty i i think i can say that
without getting demonetized
and after the death of translucent we
discover that she'd been brought in to
beef up the numbers
but she's clearly going to be cooking up
a storm because of her politics
in the original source material
stormfront was a man
that due to his views on race was put
into conflict with the other
characters aya cash will be playing
stormfront
and when talking to digital spy she said
i think stormfront is like the nuclear
bomb that goes off in the seven
maybe nuclear bomb isn't the right word
we're in chernobyl
there you go it's a chernobyl thing i
think she's here to blow up fort
she's here to get brought back to the
original idea behind creating
superheroes
and she can be quite the feminist
there's a lot of
i wouldn't say misdirect but she's also
a very
empowered woman now the nasties from
world war ii
of course believe in the aryan superman
and it is possible that stormfront will
sort of be a twist on that with their
attempting to make the vort corporation
go back to trying to make a superior
form of humanity in order to rule over
the planet
homelander is of course a blonde head
and blue-eyed superman
so he very much fits this aesthetic
which is why she seems to be fascinated
over him in the trailer
in the recent comic-con panel they
discussed the ideas and themes behind
the second season
and stated that it would tackle white
supremacy and systematic racism
whereas the first season was very much
about the metoo movement
this will instead deal with more
prevalent issues for 2020
it will also be tackling social media
and how that's weaponized to attack
certain individuals and also spread
false information
when discussing the themes the creative
team said
it's about social media it's about where
celebrity and politics
intersect it's about how people are now
packaging their political messages in
slick entertainment bites
to get the american public to act
against their own best interests
and how it's almost now
indistinguishable between the people who
have political power
and the people who have celebrity power
it's frighteningly present
i think that garth in a weird way
predicted the reality that we're living
which is just an overwhelming tsunami of
pop culture
social media and entertainment that's
being run by very very powerful people
who are only interested in furthering
their own agenda so i think
taking shots at celebrities and the
ridiculousness of celebrity life
all the trappings of entourages and
publicists and everything that goes
around it
is part of the story from the teaser we
can see that stormfront is live
streaming her first day on the job
and she divulges that though it appears
homelander and maeve are shooting a
commercial on a military base
it's actually just a set it is possible
that she could be the one that brings
the facade of the seven crashing down
by constantly posting all of their
activity online
i think that they might actually switch
it up and have her be more of a liberal
that represents cancel culture
as the new form of the character is a
complete 180 on the source material
alongside her will be patton oswald who
is currently in an unknown role
but it is possible that he will be
starring as the legend
the legend knows about all of the
skeletons in the closet that the seven
have
and this die-hard comic book fan
basically has
an encyclopedic knowledge of the ins and
outs of their weaknesses
due to his love of comic books and
superheroes as a whole
we may also potentially be getting
jeffrey dean morgan
as he did post on twitter that he was
down for being in the show
and though it was probably too late for
him to be cast in the second season
with a newly announced third it is
indeed possible
now who he could be is of course up for
debate but i would absolutely
love to see him as black noir i don't
want to spoil too much about the comic
books
as i think it's something that you
should see for yourself but they do
an absolutely amazing thing with
homeland and noir that
i think would be amazing to see with
morgan in the role
fingers crossed for that but if not i'm
sure he'll be cool in whatever capacity
he's used in
on top of that billy's dog terra will
also be featuring in an episode
hardcore fans of the comic were
disappointed that the pooch pal didn't
show up in season 1
but it has been confirmed that the
canine companion will be showing up at
some point in the second season
it's also rumored that some of the
deceased members of the cast
will be returning in the form of
flashbacks and is possible that this
series could tell the true origin story
of the boys
and some of the horrendous acts that
they carried out for their corporations
now whilst this is good news sadly
there is some bad news too unfortunately
simon pegg will not be returning
and he recently told collider that his
appearance was supposed to just be a fun
easter egg
in case you don't know in the source
material huey was based off of peg
and it was hoped that when the boys was
made into a live-action adaptation
that he would be casting the role sadly
due to his age he wasn't
and it kind of sucks that we won't be
seeing him in the show again
now before we get into the plot reveals
i just want to let you know we're giving
away a free copy of the mcu infinity
saga box set to one random subscriber
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the boys in the comments
section below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 15th of august and the set will
be shipped out from then to whoever gets
the prize
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part
now the first big plot reveal that we
discovered from comic-con is that a
train
is indeed still alive at the end of the
first season
his fate was left up in the air due to
the fact that he had a heart attack
because of his compound v addiction it
was revealed that he was saved
but that he no longer has his abilities
and the character must turn and face the
things that he's been running from for
so long
which is the person that he's turned
into in addition to this we learn that
the boys are fugitives that are on the
run
whilst this was teased in the initial
trailer it looks like this will evolve
into a worldwide manhunt
with homelander attempting to unite
humanity and tracking them down
at the end of the first season it was
revealed that butch's wife becker
was actually alive and that she was
raising homeland as son
butch's mission in this season will be
to save his wife
and whether he's willing to jeopardize
his friends in order to do this
as for homelander he'll be dealing with
the repercussions of killing stillwell
and after he finds traces of her he has
a journey of self-reflection
in which he goes on a search for love
but inevitably
he has difficulty building any kind of
connection on top of this
we will also learn about kimiko mother's
milk and frenchie
which are of course characters that we
still don't really know that much about
these will finally get some fully
fleshed out backstories that dive into
what drives them
which i definitely think will be a
really interesting aesthetic
and finally we got a brand new clip
yesterday that showed the deep
hunting after the group after running
from the law they decided to flee to the
sea but the aquaman parody was not too
far behind them
he initially commands sharks to chase
their boat before showing up on the back
of a giant whale
this creates a barricade to the inland
but rather than letting it slow them
down
butcher instead rams the boat into the
creature impaling it
and sending the deep flying it's an
awesome clip that i definitely recommend
that you check out in full
right after this anyway that should be
everything that you need to know about
the season
and make sure you keep your eyes glued
to the channel as we'll be doing a lot
of coverage on the boys before the show
airs on the 4th of september
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you
comment below about what you want to see
in the upcoming series
if you want something else to watch
after this then make sure you check out
our character breakdown on thanos
as we go over everything that you need
to know about marvel's mad titan
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content like this early then
please consider clicking the join button
below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter anyway
that's everything in the video
thank you for making it until the end
you've been the best i've been
definition and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you